ونذهب الى التطورات في البرازيل تضيق
السلطات البرازيليه الخناقه حول المشاركين
والمنظمين والممولين لاعمال الشعب الاخيره
في برازيليا حيث دفعت الاحداث الرئيس لولا
دا سيلفا الى اعاده تنظيم الفريق الامني
في القصر الرئاسي بعد اعتقاده بوجود
مسؤولينا موالنا للرئيس السابق جرير
سونارو فتحوا ابواب القصر الرئاسي امام
المتظاهرين وبالتزامن طلب مكتب المدعي
العام الفيدرالي تجميده مبالغه بقيمته
مليون ومئتين الف يورو لاثنتين وخمسين
شخصيه وسبع شركات متهمه بتمويل نقل مثير
الشرق
بموت
كده العديد من الضباط يتعاونون مع من
الشهب كذلك عناصر الشرطه العسكريه
متواطئون العديد من عناصر القوات المسلحه
هدى في الداخل ايضا متواطئون انا مقتنع
تماما بان بابا قصر لانالدو تم فتحه لدخول
المتظاهرين لانه لا يوجد اي باب تمره وهذا
يعني ان احدهم سهل عمليه دخوله
البرازيليه
مرحبا بك سيد هاني على ما يبدو ان هناك
اعتقاد لدى رئيس البرازيليه ان تمت مؤامره
داخليه قد تمت لسماح للمتظاهرين بالدخول
الى القصر رئاسي هل من معلومات تفصيليه
حول هذا الامر
مساء الخير لحضرتك والاستاده المتابعين
تماما يوم الاحد الاسود كما يسمونه
البرازيليون ما زال له تبعاته الامنيه
بشكل خاص يوم الامس بالذات تم كشف عن
وثيقه كان يعدها السكرتير الامني لولايه
البرازيليه سيد اندرس
وهو كان يشغل وايضا منصب وزير العدل
السابق في الحكومه لجارب سوناريو كان ذلك
مسوده
طبعا النتائج الانتخابيه هذا يعطي مؤشر
كبير على تورط شخصيه مهمه جدا في التحضير
لشيء مصطفى وكل ما حدث من اعماله شغب كانت
همم طبعا باعتقال كثيرين هي معده مصطفى
سعيد
الشخصيه هويه هذه الشخصيه هل يمكنك التوقع
او التنبؤ بها
جدا من رئيس جرير بوسوناري وخلال احداث
الاقتحام هو كان متواجد في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه يدفعنا هذا الشيء طبعا
الى ما صرحت عنه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه في الايام الماضيه بانها مستعده
للتعاون الاستخبارات ايضا للكشف عن ان كان
هنالك لقاء قد جمع ما بين جرير سوناريو ما
بين اندرياس توريس تم هذا الامر فهو يعتبر
دليل قوي جدا على تورط ايضا الرئيس جرير
بوسوناريو في ما سبق من احداث وما حدث في
يوم الاحد الاسود اما على الصعيد الامني
وصعيد الاطباق تم اعفاء قائد الشرطه
العسكريه ال- ال- العقيده من منصبه يوم
امس وذلك نتيجه طبعا اعمال التراخي هنالك
التحقيقات ما زالت مستمره اكثر من 1,000
شخص طبعا يتم التحقيق معهم الكثير من
التسجيلات الصوتيه وايضا التسجيلات
المرئيه نشرها بين الحين والاخر لما تم من
احداث وما تم من تسهيلات ايضا من قبل
القوات الشرطه وايضا كان هنالك فيديو لاف
جدا للنظر وهو كان حوار شديد جدا ما بين
الشرطه العسكريه وما بين اعضاء للجيش وذلك
حيث ان القوات الجيش كانت تتعامل بشكل
جدا متساهل مع المتسهرين بينما عدد صفات
الشرطه كامله
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه بتسليم
هنالك اتفاقيات بتسليم ال ال طبعا
المجرمين كما دعانا نسميهم تحت اطار
المجرمين بين الدولتين ولكن لغايه اللحظه
التحقيقات ما زالت مستمره في حاله ثبت
ادانه او وجود اي تدخل مباشر من قبل
الرئيس جاين بوسناري بكل تاكيد سوف تتقدم
الحكومه البرازيليه بطلب لتسليم جير
بوسناريو بشكل مباشر لكن جيرب سوناري نفسه
اعلن خلال اليومين الماضيين بانه سوف يعود
للبرازيل في نهايه الشهر الحالي ايضا
اندرس المتهم ال- ال- الاكبر في ال- ال-
القضيه قضيه الاقتحامات همم ايضا قال بانه
سوف يعود هنالك مذكره اعتقال بحلقه
وبالتالي بمجرد وصوله الى البرازيل سوف
يتم اعتقاله من قبل الشرطه الاتحاديه اذا
ما زالت سيد هاني الصحفي من سن باولو
البرازيليه